[Inaudible].
What's up guys, Jared here,
the name Sterling Archer brings to mind a few glorious. If disturbing images,
whizzing bullets that rarely hit anything bloody Mary's for breakfast and an
adult secret agent with a category four edible complex.
My head hurts and I have no father, but what if.
Paying attention to who raised Archer could give us greater insights into some
of his more unique quirks?
Well, sit here, dress like some sort of capital rapist.
No, not his mom. Have you seen the show?
We mean the reliable friend who guided him through his most formative years.
That's right. The glowing screen of parental guidance and cultural formation,
the TV, because it may be Archer's profound bond with 1980 cinema and TV.
I no longer wish to be represented by TVs. Michael Gray can help us.
I understand his inability to form healthy bonds with human beings. Now,
most American kids put in a solid amount of time in front of the magical box of
wonders, but ideally it serves as a source of entertainment,
not as a stand in for, you know, necessary human interactions.
So if we want to understand what makes Archer so archery,
we need to look at how his childhood consumption of film and television turned
him into the sort of adult who thinks this is normal.
I don't care Pam. Now having said that,
would you please come in this dirty toilet stall and have sex with me?
So let's find out how being raised on screen can seriously screw a person up in
this wisecrack edition on Archer,
raised by TV and as always spoilers ahead. But before we jump in,
I want to take a second to remind you to check your voter registration status.
This week, we're partnering with global citizen,
a nonpartisan organization to help you learn more about participating in the
upcoming November 3rd election.
If you haven't checked out your registration status since 2016 now is the time
to do it since we're only 39 days away from the presidential election.
Make sure all your info is up to date and make a plan to vote.
When you check your status with global citizen,
you can also enter to win cool rewards from popular artists like Billie Eilish,
Lenny Kravitz, and more visit the Lincoln description for more information.
And now back to the show in case you've been on the Archer family,
liquid diet and forgot what the show is about a quick refresher archers for
seven seasons take place in a vaguely cold war S timeline, uh,
shares all of our pop culture points of reference.
Garate the Dane cook of martial arts.
Playing fast and loose with everything else. Archer who works for his mother,
Mallory is a top tier international spy with a pension for booze Lee bungling
missions. Oh, also for the past few seasons, he's been in a lifeless coma,
but the show goes on inside his bizarre unconscious,
as he dreams up new adventures for his team set everywhere from 1940s LA to
outer space. As we see through flashbacks in the series,
Archer's childhood was not great. His mom abandoned him as a baby,
leaving him under the care of a stiff British Butler and heroin addict Woodhouse
upon her return.
His mother makes up for lost time by moving houses and accidentally forgetting
to Archer. Just.
Like that Christmas break.
When I moved and forgot to give my new address to his stupid boarding school.
She also steals a spike to teach him a lesson.
Stole my bike. I came home from work and it was just lying on the sidewalk.
And I thought, Oh, well, this will teach him.
Beats him with a paddle.
When he cries and turns him into a full fledged gambling addict and alcoholic
before he loses all his baby teeth, real mother of the year stuff.
My mom had told me how much she loved me all the time. Exactly.
Look how you turned out.
We don't know much else about his childhood, but none of it seemed great.
He once spent five weeks in the hospital after getting a hardcore prep school
swirly. However,
we do know that Archer's childhood hero was none other than the pride of Florida
state university, Burt Reynolds.
This suggests that Archer was busy forming attachments to the people on his TV
screen.
Well then we better keep Dr. Bellows away from genie. No.
While his mom was out doing spy stuff and his caretaker was in doing heroin
stuff while we don't actually see Archer watching TV, the pop culture,
he absorbed as a kid, clearly functions as a crucial layer of his character.
We know they're building a Gundam suit with bazookas for ham.
And being raised by television puts Archer right at home in modern culture where
kids between two and five spend about 32 hours a week watching the boob tube.
Coincidentally,
that's also how much time I spend each week wondering what would he would say to
me if granted the power of human speech. But anyway,
if Archer spent his childhood absorbing ad-based content while being profoundly,
socially isolated and ignored by his sole parental figure,
what are the longterm effects?
Let's start with one of the most crucial aspects of childhood development,
learning, quote unquote, normal cultural and social practices, for instance,
saying, please,
and thank you knowing the boundaries of polite conversation and so on.
Most kids pick this stuff up via their family school church or local dojo
learning this stuff helps us functionally participate in society and get along
with others.
It also helps us develop healthy social boundaries so that we don't get an
erection in front of our mother inspired by the thought of her dying.
The thought of me, Dan gives you any rock shot.
But Archer who grew up essentially parentless friendless,
and without any cultural or religious structure lacks the type of socialization
that most functional members of society have.
That's a big reason why he has such a hard time connecting with other people and
always seems hopelessly out of sync with his colleagues, lovers and friends.
It's ironic, isn't it? I'm not sure that's technically irony what this is like.
Oh,
Henry and Ilana's Morissette had a baby and named it this exact
situation. Oh yes it is.
Instead of learning about culture, through observing genuine human interactions,
Archer has learned everything through the small screen and his reactions to a
whole number of scenarios.
Show that he'd be more at home in an episode of mash banks, radar,
or the Flintstones kick in at bedrock style than he ever is in the normal world.
He can't even appreciate Krieger being a good listener without comparing him to
Oprah B best conversationalists on daytime television.
Seriously Krieger. You are. My Archer's problem.
Is that he's unable to draw a clear line of demarcation between the world,
as it appears on screen and the real world a study carried out by the Canadian
pediatric society on the effects of television viewing on child development
found that the inability of young children to distinguish everyday reality from
what happens on screen,
along with their efforts to make sense of competing experiential realms may
interfere with and impede executive function,
which is to say the difficulty of separating between real life and TV life as a
child,
and eventually make real life adult tasks like separating our professional lives
from our sex lives,
more difficult Archer's own problem and distinguishing the screen world from the
real world bleeds into every aspect of his life from his blunt seduction
techniques to his over the top spy antics in Archer's TV, addled brain,
every real life mansion is probably hiding a Scrooge McDuck style coin vault in
the basement.
Somewhere in this mansion,
I have to assume is a gigantic Scrooge McDuck involved.
But even more basic to becoming a functional human is understanding how language
works. That doesn't just mean the literal definition of words,
but also how they function in a social context.
It's knowing that the phrase it's lit doesn't mean the party house is on fire.
And our buddy Sterling did learn about the social function of language from
observing organic human interactions or from a helpful teacher or therapist.
He learned it by absorbing dialogue written by a room full of Ivy league grads
and sweatpants see normal human language revolves around communicating ideas,
subtext and the nuances of human emotion.
But the dialogue in movies and television serves the purpose of creating
entertaining narratives and keeping easily distracted eyeballs glued to the
screen because of this is often laced with the type of over the top verbiage.
That might sound normal when the rock says it,
but would be ridiculous in real life. A bad-ass line might read on screen.
[Inaudible].
But probably won't work when shouted in a rowdy Dave and busters Archer's
attempts at bad-ass Surrey are always imbued with a hint of patheticness in
trying to imitate what he saw on screen. He becomes a caricature.
Something about I rescue Ilana, and she begs me to take her back.
So then she will commit suicide. I swear to God, I had something for this.
That's because our buddy Sterling's conception of language was shaped not by
interacting with his peers, but by observing rousing onscreen dialogue,
at least he didn't grow up on Gilmore girls.
They talk so fast and all that coffee is to stall too much.
In the moments just before the act. Well, God,
we were actually discussing modern day Marxism in America,
which is not what I would have deemed to come and get it sort of conversation.
But nevertheless,
he came and got it and I have to figure out what that means to me on a
psychological level.
There's no more obvious example of this than Archer's favorite way to call out
perceived innuendo, um, phrasing,
because TV both wants to be sexy and appealed to your grandma and Poughkeepsie.
It often realize unveiled sexual references, innuendos that we all kind of get,
but don't really raise eyebrows.
And while these jokes may be normal in the conference room of Dunder Mifflin,
that's what she says in the real world. People usually just mean what they say,
especially in the workplace,
but because Archer's brain expects and dialogue and not conversation,
he sees this type of thing everywhere. Even when he can barely get a word out,
he can always muster up a phrasing.
And while Archer has a pretty good vocabulary,
his whole understanding of the social function of language seems to be deeply
shaped by years of consuming TV. As a result.
He not only misreads things said by others.
That thought you put it on autopilot.
Dan's course in altitude.
It doesn't know how to find VOE air strip within a thousand miles.
So it can learn itself when it needs gas. And I, uh, misunderstood the question.
But also says wildly offensive or out of bound things only to be surprised that
they didn't go over smoothly.
Hey, you want to smell something?
John speed dial.
He talks to normal folks like he's playing the role of an American James Bond
reboot, which I mean he is, but you get what I'm saying now.
We're not trying to say the consuming too much pop culture has made Archer dub
far from it. The guy is able to drop a Herman Melville reference on a dime.
I would prefer not to.
Bartleby the Scrivener, anybody.
And he speaks like 10 languages.
Yeah. There's cards [inaudible].
But because he considers Hollywood speak to be what's normative,
he's left perpetually out of sync when conversing with others.
It's like trying to learn how to drive a car by watching the fast and the
furious movies.
What makes perfect sense on screen only leads to you flipping your Ford Fiesta
in real life. But my God, is it a glorious right up until that point? Of course,
this is Archer's problem.
He's learned how to be human through observing what he's seen in fictional
programming meant to entertain, not educate. Now,
obviously we'd be remiss not to mention Archer's most obnoxious quality is super
hyper, definitely troubling, overcompensating, masculine.
But I've also cut back on, you know.
On VOD, certainly with you that could almost literally be.
Anonymous sex. If you must know.
Contemporary version of Hollywood,
masculinity is often someone slight and hairless like Timothy Charlemagne
Archer's version of masculinity was shaped by the previously mentioned pile of
perfect chest hair with the human growing out of it. Burt Reynolds,
famous for playing the charming bad-ass who beats your by day and seduces your
wife by night.
Reynolds had an iconic run of films in the seventies and eighties and was a
massive.
[Inaudible].
Of course, Reynolds was an actor playing too hyped up masculine stereotypes,
not an actual human being embodying them, but for a young Archer,
he was the model of manhood, a sort of 2d father figure,
filling the whole lift by his biological father's absence and not to get too
Freudian. But the one-time Archer meets his real father.
He gives him a stuffed alligator for his birthday.
Archer's favorite Reynolds film, none other than the 1976 classic Gator.
So Archer's projection of a father figure onto Mr. Reynolds is not without some
sort of reptilian connection. Oh,
and it's kind of vaguely in play that Reynolds could be Archer's father.
So maybe the Gator thing is less Freudian and more.
No. Remember how I said, I kind of have a date. It was kind of with your mom,
regardless.
Masculinity is the most important thing.
And if it means one thing for Sterling Archer,
it means sex lots and lots of sex sex, basically whenever,
wherever. And with whomever.
One of the only times in the show that he seems to actively avoid sex is when he
meets a 16 year old,
but he bookends their interaction by asking her to hit him up.
When she turns 18.
Literally the minute you turn 18, please call me.
Lassie. I know,
but it's a shocking that someone who learned everything from TV and film would
have this view of sex.
Shoot him Sierra, but just him. I think the twins are warming up to me, right?
Are you guys getting some sinks.
After all,
even most commercials have a sexual angle that guarantees if you buy the right
body spray, you'll immediately be swimming in intercourse.
And those are just things that play in between all the shows and movies,
where in the final analysis,
everything was really about someone successfully getting laid.
As we noted in a previous video,
much of Archer's persona seems modeled around James Bond,
who was basically Burt Reynolds that went to an English prep school and has
fancy gadgets. And if you've seen even nine seconds of a James Bond film,
you've seen him seducing a woman named something like hungry bottoms or furry
kitten.
So why wouldn't Archer's personality largely revolve around the utter importance
of affirming his masculinity by sleeping with women?
It's not like he was exposed to any other model of how a guy should act or exist
in a relationship,
but pay Archer's twisted upbringing at least kind of comes together.
At one point when the real Burt Reynolds,
his ideal father figure ends up sleeping with his mom.
Meaning for drinks. I mean,
obviously sex was implied since when is he your hero Archer?
He tries to break them up and kidnaps may be Papa Burt,
but the two eventually kind of bond and Bert gives Archer some insight on his
fear of emotional vulnerability.
I don't care about them. Yes you do.
You just pretend you don't because you're afraid.
Illusion of real Burt Reynolds in the episode seems like further evidence that
the creators of the show know that watching one dimensional Reynolds characters
ruined Archer,
but also that seeing the emotional complexity of the real bird just might help
him grow. Of course,
while most of us don't have tinnitus from a lifetime of bullets whizzing by our
ears and somehow not killing us.
This is what I was talking about, but the whole tinnitus thing.
Any of us have spent more hours than we might want to admit staring at screens
and theaters and living rooms and on our phones while we take our ninth bathroom
break at work.
So maybe we're all a bit more like Archer than we'd like to think.
But what do you think wisecrack is Archer a case study and why?
Sometimes we need to step away from the screens and learn how to be human,
or are we just using this show to work through our own childhood abandonment
issues? Let us know in the comments as always Matt,
thanks to our patrons for all your support hit that subscribe button.
Like it's the source of your emotional dysfunction and as always,
thanks for watching guys. Peace.
[Inaudible].